j'arrivais à bien des cafés vendus dans
le monde
merci
monsieur vous avez tout ce qu'il vous
faut la wii à propos de cette cassette
je crois que c'est un film os x vous en
voyez souvent dotés en même temps
lorsque j'ai des amis qui viennent à la
maison pour passer un bon petit beau
match c'est rigolo cette histoire qui
est de la vidéo là dans la boucherie ces
pratiques
dans le village d'à côté le boucher
n'était pas d'accord alors le café a
pris le relais
avec ce film c'est l'avenir et aider gb
numéro un de ceux là j'ai passé une
bonne nuit dernière liste allait revoir
lancés ici les gens viennent bien de
boire un coup le loup de cassettes des x
x des fois c'était une belle aventure
quand c'est un hit s'il constate quand
même que la cassette n'était pas vu
entièrement les débits n'est qu'à moitié
ce qui prouve bien que quand même les
jeunes sans la recette très facilement